tain c'est un hommage au travail qu'il a
effectuée depuis là depuis 1998 qui
était peut-être la première date où il a
pris une réelle conscience de ce
problème qu'il fallait s'attacher à
résoudre
et quand il a produit son fameux texte
nous nous souvenons qui reconnaissait
l'esclavagé crimes contre l'humanité
texte qu'il a fait signer par 400
personnes de son entourage et qu'il a
portée je crois la vie de simple de
schoelcher et puis quelques années plus
tard il a créé l'association tous
créoles en partenariat en échangeant
avec gérard lanvin carter et cette
association qui a fait tomber beaucoup
de murs qui a qu'à mener de profondes
réflexions de
dont l'objectif consiste à rapprocher
les communautés rapprochés les uns et
les autres pour construire mieux vivre
ensemble et ce livre retrace ses grandes
étapes retrace les textes fondateurs de
son action et quand on relit ce travail
en prend conscience de l'ampleur de du
travail qu'il a pu effectuer pendant ces
quelques années
alors quand vous dites 400 personnes
c'est-à-dire 400 bus qui ont reconnu que
l'esclavagé est un crime contre
l'humanité absolument 400 et 1 400 noms
qui ont et qu'ils sont à peser sur ceux
sur les registres de ce texte c'est ça a
été fait en 1998
c'est à dire trois ans avant que
christiane taubira le promulgue la loi
qui reconnaît l'esclavagé crimes contre
l'humanité donc d'une certaine manière
roger à anticiper les choses
il l'a fait un moment où le débat
n'était pas ouvert donc il a le courage
de de mettre sur la table un sujet qui
était difficile il a fait une époque où
un tas d'anecdotes est pas donc ce
n'était pas par voie de mail que que ces
signatures ont été obtenues mais bien
par des échanges directs par des
contacts directs et je crois que cette
action démontre sa vraie volonté son
véritable engagement et son envie de
débattre sur le fond du sujet ce qu'il a
fait pendant plusieurs mois puisque ces
signatures encore une fois résulte
d'action de rencontre extrêmement
concrètes et extrêmement engageante
vous l'avez fait en 2006 lors de 22 mai
à fort de france
vous étiez plusieurs et ce texte hérité
ce texte a été lu effectivement lors
d'une série de la cérémonie du 22 mai à
fort de france il a été lu par roger at
il été entendu
probablement parce qu'ils étaient sur
place mais c'est vrai que ce jour là
était un jour particulier puisque c'est
la première fois qu'autant de mékhé
participer à un 22 mai et je crois que
c'était un moment extrêmement fort et
qui était cas était un marqueur
également de l'avis de tous créoles
puisque dans les statuts mêmes de cette
association sont inscrits est inscrit
par dont le l'obligation de célébrer le
22 mai donc c'est ça a été inscrit dans
les statuts et chaque 22 mai
l'association célèbre cette date